anara gupta thank you so much for coming
on the show good to be here
it's been really nice
getting to know you and
getting to
really feel where you're coming from and
what you
share with the collective
coming from honor which we'll be talking
about
it's been also fun sort of getting to
know about
your
desire to
know
um what the nature of reality is and um
sort of the spark
that
um
led you to that um to realization and
also to um then
uh sharing
um
so i'd like to talk about that i'd like
to talk about what sparked your interest
in truth i'd like to talk about the
patterns of consciousness that you've
been seeing um
from the
50 000 people that you've impacted
positively across the world
and also what coming from honor is and
um it's been nice having you lead the
sessions here the last two for the limit
society and you've been sharing that
like cleaning up is another thing that i
feel like we'll talk about so let's um
let's go through the through that order
so let's start with truth so like what
was it you were born in northeast india
you moved to canada when you're four
um what was it that sparked your desire
for truth
i don't know if any i don't know i don't
think i've had any desire for truth i i
uh
if there was a transition point i came
out of university started some
businesses
around my businesses
uh with the real commitment everybody
just really loving their time so my
staff loved working there my customers
loved dude and came in and
you know just wanted people to be happy
and then uh then i did to develop myself
did some courses in the world of
personal transformation
i go oh
what was more important to me than the
business of photography or design was
people being happy and here's a business
just about people being happy so i think
i'll go to that
i didn't i've never thought about truth
or not just what would make life better
for people and making life better for
people can be synonymous with truth yeah
it is i just i also realize deeper into
it i have no idea what's true i just
know this is what i want to do
nice
so around university or so was the time
that no after i started my business
cool and then i've when i did my first
program in this area so in my business i
created i wanted people to be really
happy with this that and then i did some
trainings and in that oh wow there's
trainings there's work that's business
just about having people live better
lives
so it was probably a few years into
but two three years into my business
so yeah simple just having people live
better lives
happier trying to make life better
yeah
oh i actually like that more than
anything
yeah making life better and this is
another theme that
will come up is just the way anurag just
makes things simple
um and uses great analogies for it so
yeah just simple making life better
okay and then
what did you
see
when you were uh that was maybe what 20
years ago
almost 30.
i've been doing this work for almost 30
years
nice yeah
cool so
since so over these last three decades
then you began seeing okay how do i make
life better and what was sort of the
beginning of what that was like
of uh of that and then how it's evolved
now to just even a single word honor
single intention well i started it's the
first time i did you know a personal
development program and then i saw oh
there's uh
there's some knowledge about
yourself that you can access that i
didn't know before before i learned
english math this that oh there's a
different type of education look at that
and uh so i i then go okay good well
that's just like i i enjoyed learning
other stuff i said this okay i'm gonna
learn more about this
i was in the early 90s
and
uh so then i
did some more programs than as people do
and then i became involved in the
the
i started getting i got trained to
deliver as i saw that was what i wanted
to do more of to do that work
i moved through the ranks of
training getting trained delivering
delivering designing
training trainers
developing like that and that because i
could see always more as possible
and then after 10 12 years of that 12
years of that i
hit kind of the top of there and i still
saw more possible and i asked people hey
do you want to let's can they they know
they wanted to deliver what they had not
explored the next level but i could see
more was possible and then i said on the
path that led me here
and that was i had a view
when i stepped into that i saw that it
was possible to make a significant
impact in the world and i said okay
that's what my life's about is to
transform life on the planet
and i thought i was doing it
and then
after like 10 years in i i was i had an
idea and i thought stop and i said i had
a view that like because every week i'm
doing programs working with others all
the stuff other there's other things
around the world that people are
engaging in you know
and i go wow you know we're getting
every day closer to critical mass more
people are doing this something's gonna
happen
i always have a suspicion about my own
views so one day i had a thought and i
decided i'm gonna do some math and i
researched everything i could about
every type of program like this how many
people are doing them what's happening
right and i took that number i doubled
it
because i'll obviously miss some
and then i look compared that to the
population growth and i found that the
population growth was a thousand times
the number of people doing this kind of
work
and so actually we're not approaching
critical mass we're moving away from
critical mass by a factor of 10
every year
but my arrogant view was because i was
only looking at what was around me it
felt like we were growing
or not that is a percentage you get what
i'm saying yeah so you go oh
i thought i was creating a tipping point
but i'm actually
what i'm doing is moving away from the
tipping point
so either i keep my word
to make the difference on the planet or
i revoke my word and just go back to
making a difference and they're two
different things
and if i'm going to make a difference i
know how to do it i'm doing it if i want
to make the difference i thought it was
but i'm not so now i'm gonna have to
figure out how
so i decided to keep my word and then
just and spent and spent some time since
then trying to figure out how
which which that is the path that led me
to the honor because part of how is that
it's got to be clear simple distinct
so i've been working at the distillation
and things like that so that's one of
the things that's the key thing that led
me to here
so
when you're
like 30 years ago you're honing in on
making life better and then you're
seeing some of the
patterns
of
mostly would you say like uh people in
in business
um
no i mean what i what i mean i was in
business
let me just think the thing about it i
wasn't looking for the patterns when i
was in business when i was in business i
was just a happy guy trying to make life
better for people
when i did the programs i said oh look
at that these guys have an understanding
of some of the patterns human being and
when i went into that it went on to that
first in the dorm of personal
development
yeah
cool
and then it
grew to organizational and then when i
took on the world then i started to look
and study for patterns
at the beginning was just uh that my
beginning was how to empower people
and so initially when it's like personal
development and how to empower people
and then we'll get to the larger
organizations in the world
so that it was
sort of around um
empowerment and and what would that look
like it would be like getting through a
limiting belief seeing oneself as
powerful as able to make change yeah i
mean the thing is to me all of that
didn't matter i didn't care whatever
would make them happier
you know there's a long list of those
things if you're in the moment it's what
does that person need what's in the way
it's like it was never that complicated
for me about what are all these
different i just [ __ ] i don't care it's
like what uh
what we'll set this person free
let's find it
nice okay
okay so then what will set this person
free what will make them happier
um
so it's usually an orientation towards
the person's intention for what they
find to be happy or freedom no most time
i discovered they were wrong about that
most of the things that people were
chasing would not leave them happy or
free
it would what would authentically
actually leave them happy and free
whatever that is
so there's a philosophy around it at the
same time
it's still complicated to me dude it's
like this people think oh and i get that
car then i'll be happy and they get
their car they're not happy
yeah right so it's it's just
not we don't have to i don't have any
interest in any of that terminology
there's just actually doing the work
and understanding what actually leaves
people joyful and free and having them
in fact the thing is most reason they're
not is because they think these things
do and they're working on those things
they're not even working on their joy
and freedom they're working on other
things they think we'll give them that
but don't
yeah
is it different for different people
yeah some of it is and some of it's
common for everybody but it's actually
hey let's get to it
and let's get you oriented some of it is
to get you actually realizing hey oh
that won't do it for me what really will
and then let's figure out how to have
that happen
yeah yeah that's that's the component
that i was um hinting at because
there is a
at the same time as it's the person
becoming um
seeking to be happier more free there's
also um within what you're sharing with
them is are you do you really feel like
that car is going to make you happy i
don't asking that because there are i
already know it's not yeah i'm saying
dude that's not going to do it yeah so
one of the things is here if you want to
get this you understand i'm going to
take a flamethrower even to all the
complexity with which you asked me these
questions that's that actually is in the
way yes
yeah i wanted to paint out at least
somewhat of a
uh
for the audience to be able to see okay
well this is sort of how like anarch
sort of came to what he uh feels like is
uh his honor today
um but i feel like we already that is it
that is it it's like his honor is to
have you go to have you get dude all
lots of that stuff you're working on you
know what's not honor is like fine oh
let's help you get that stuff and do
this and you pay me and i'll help you
get that stuff and there's no honor in
that
yeah
so that this is that this is how it came
to that
it's like oh hey let's help you get that
watch people get that and then they
weren't any happier go okay actually
yeah and you know
and the thing is you could totally uh
harness a lot of business by helping
people get the things that they say that
they want
but leaving them no happier
[Music]
so the real integrity for me was okay
let's do the real work some you know
that is that what i'm talking about is
actually i got there
okay so yeah it sounds like we should
just yeah go right into the the heart of
it then uh even more so
so that's probably enough of a
of a
story that sort of got to
where you're at
um
so you like you said take a flamethrower
to the complexity yeah and so then
let's go straight at the heart of it
which is
you uh have shared that you feel like
there's five core areas for people to
clean up
like where they're coming from
um
like your physical space
uh your relationships the administration
of life health and fitness your state of
being
and
when you clean those up incrementally
one by one
you sort of level up they get more
challenging over time more subtle
um
and you can sort of tell that you feel
more free you feel more happy you feel
like you're more able to serve others
yep yep yeah okay
and so this is the distillation of those
patterns that we were sort of talking
about over the couple of decades
and
so you say
for for people that um
that want to be in service
the first thing is clean
up just do the work
yeah
it's like uh yes
you know the the thing about it is
uh
so let's talk about some patterns right
so one of the patterns that got revealed
you could say there's this thing of
people just being self-serving
and that's a pattern of how they're
grades in the world and do this and take
care of yourself and then there's this
but then there's you get into some
people make the the transition some
people just are that way oh the world of
what looks like being of service
but it's not it's about doing things for
others but there's a sacrifice element a
martyr element
uh
doing it to
look good to others or even just to
yourself or to feel good
truly service there's none of that it's
simply now
so what happens is
i discovered one pattern which is that
i discovered many but here's a core one
right
so
what it was interesting because i
thought it was behind one thing but i
just i have a view now it's behind
everything which is whether it's about
being self-serving or whether about the
sacrificial service of others or
validation service of others
there's a state of being in within
oneself that is not completely in peace
completely at peace and quiet
right
and then we do then we go so then how do
we
what do we do to um
compensate for or
help us feel better against that
disquiet
so we may go chase things for ourselves
cars and
drinks or sex or this that or
see this is the part that's subtle and i
own this all of this is my view but then
actually coming from there
going to make a difference of others is
the same thing as a car
do you get what i'm saying yeah it's
just offsetting that this quiet
it's just a different drug
so i said oh my god this pattern rose
like how come this and how come they're
still not completely at peace and
satisfied how come this and
oh it's all coming down to the same
thing
so i did all this work to help people
say achieve this here in business or
achieve this in service and that still
there was a lack of total peace still
they could get knocked off their game
so i guess
distilled down further and what's behind
what was the common elements well and i
realized oh
the things that we are not absolutely at
peace with in our life create a set of
actions for us to compensate for that
and then i realized that i was actually
doing people a disservice by giving them
more ways to compensate
[Laughter]
and hide from that which really i
believe needed to be done
which is clean everything up have your
life in a state where when you look at
every corner of it you go yes
i'm good
then i trust what comes next because
what comes next is a creation purely by
choice not a reaction to that which is
unsettled in your life
that's one i think one of the most
critical
patterns that reveal itself by by
working on
every every line of action or outcome i
could think of a business outcome a
personal outcome service you know like
every and none of them all of them still
left something missing because
that what what we call the cleanup there
was was uh was not everything was not
whole in the background
let me actually give you one an example
that stands out for me
so
you know what something is not a whole
and then i'm trying to do something to
make a difference for you i'm doing it
for myself
so i can feel better
i remember i was doing this leadership
training
for a colleague of mine said would you
come in and do a session and i came in
he said these are you know doing work
like this people want to be developed in
leadership and this woman was talking
about her frustration at her office she
saw there's a one of her co-workers
who's struggling with something and she
keeps trying to use the stuff and give
her what will make a difference and she
keeps pushing back and i was listening
and listening i go oh
notice your frustration she said yeah
that's because you
want to make the difference you want her
to get it why so you can feel like i did
it it's not even about her
because she's like i can't get the
woman's dealing with her stuff i have
stuff that helps you will not listen
and then she we went into it and she
went the next week to talk to that woman
apologized for her to her
for uh wanting to support a fixture for
her own
you know self-worth and not you know for
her sorry i'm sorry i i was talking like
this is about you but it was really
about me and i i wanted to i wanted you
to get it so i could feel like i won
and it was really about me and uh and so
she all she did was say that and clean
it up and leave her alone and she said
the woman came to her the next day and
asked her for her support
you get the difference yeah
it's easy to hide out
and be more justified in our behavior
when what we're doing is
of
helping others but if it's still about
us it's still all the same thing at
least from my view
yeah this is now i feel like we're
really diving into to the heart of it
um
so you gave
the example where you look around and
you feel like your life is clean you
feel like um you are you know purely
expressing yourself in service
and you're not doing it for
self-interest
you're doing it
actually to serve other people and to
serve the planet
and
and that
cleaning up is like polishing the
diamond
you could say yeah you could say
and
we have had a a good amount of um
content on our channel about
spirituality and the nature of reality
so just you know briefly to say that um
the mud on the diamond
is like being caught by illusion
being caught by separation
um
being caught by your lowercase s self
and the polishing of the mud
is to see uh true nature to
to see all as you
and
so so then you have a slightly different
view of it
please which is uh i would say to see
more clearly
but i don't know if i ever get to true
nature
or what is
yeah i think that's a bit assumptive and
arrogant
every time i i get more clear
then i see what was off about how i used
to see it why do i think now is the
truth
all i have evidence for is that i'm
always wrong
yeah
or yeah no ground is another way to
yeah so incrementally
gaining more insight into nature that i
would say yeah yeah
nice
okay cool and
so insight
plays a role
in purifying where you're coming from
but also just
cleaning up itself
um
catalyzes
uh
purity and where you're coming from
that's my experience yes
yeah
and it does so more than insight
you you do find that to be significant
indifference yeah or actually i could
say it's 100 different like insight
doesn't produce anything actively
applying insight does yes
and when you're cleaning up it's just
active
so it's a hundred percent impact insight
is zero percent impact insight acted
upon with honor is impact but insight is
zero impact
cool i can actually demonstrate that
insight can have a negative impact
because if you have an insight
and then you don't act on it
you actually now making and then make
yourself wrong for not acting at it and
thinking about it and stuff like that
you've actually diminished your your
energy
this reminds me a lot of when we've had
all these different scientists in their
fields on our show as well many of them
say that they're sick of writing papers
that
only a couple handfuls of other
scientists around the world can
understand so they begin saying things
like applied neuroscience so how do you
take and
apply the insights that you're gaining
from the scientific advancements into
the actual fabric of the world in
relatable ways and so that that rings uh
really true is uh your insight
needs to
be
um applied it's like applied insight or
applied cleanup um
really resonant
and then that's playing and so this is
another great analogy that honor has
been using a lot is soccer or like
playing the game like the applying
insight is playing the game applying
cleanup is playing soccer yeah
otherwise you could imagine that you
went to uh you know for me coming
watching this
going to a workshop whatever is like
in the soccer game is like uh
the locker room
it's not the game
it's the locker room
now imagine if you always went to the
locker room and never got on the field
people think why are you doing it yeah
what's the point
does it have value yeah if you come out
of the locker room and apply
the strategy otherwise it would be weird
yeah
yeah we're watching film could be
another example it's like that you just
watch film and watch film but you never
go and apply it in the game
yeah
so what why are you doing it you could
say i'm just sure to be entertained but
then just say that
but the locker room and that's not for
entertainment that's for the game
okay great this is an awesome
distinction so we have
because many of us have come from a
place of
um suffering or have come from a place
of wanting to live incrementally happier
um be at peace
and
the first thing that came was
well i'm now i'm seeking and i'm seeking
mostly like video content or books or
retreats or whatever it is and then we
we
we find some sort of um
uh we find ourselves in some sort of
process of well when do i reach a
threshold of applying the insights
um that i'm learning from these
different teachers or retreats or books
content
um when do i take it from a passive
place of consuming content to
a
place of actually applying it
um
and making a positive difference in the
world
and i like that that's that's the
transition from like watching film
seeking and watching film
to
uh going and playing the game and then
just transitioning more and more of your
time to playing the game
and
the thing is though i recommend and
that's why i don't do all the
traditional workshop anymore is i'm like
don't come if you're not going to play
i'm interested in that transition that
blah blah blah blah why are you even
here see the thing is when you're seven
years old and you're going to the
locker room you're there to play you
don't go huh i wonder when i'll apply
what i heard in the locker room yeah
take the [ __ ] over it
don't come if you're not going to play
we sort of have these
long distinguishing conversations
because it's not necessary which
validates like there's some barrier in
the way to just do it
yeah
and i found what you said recently to be
really helpful as well which is
that
um as i've went through my own cleanup
last two weeks that you've been here
that every single time that i make an
incremental advancement there's a
opening up it's like peace and happiness
open up
um not only for myself but for who i'm
like especially in like the relationship
one uh then peace and happiness also
opens up for them which is beautiful
and then almost with either right away
or within a couple hours or the next day
it's like the next level shows up where
i remember or like the next thing in the
room to clean that's right it showed
that's right
and so then it's having courage and
fearlessness which you talked about in
mere talks uh episode 12 with bentino
and
to take on the cleanup itself
and i think it would probably be helpful
because i do think that our audience um
uh overlaps uh quite a bit with um with
continued no limit society but also does
not and so i do think that it would be
beneficial for those that do not
to get a taste of what is being shared
at no lemon society by maybe having you
break down in a little bit of detail at
least
um what the those five things that we
covered what are some like classical
examples for people in those five
sure i mean let's take your physical
space you know so i tell people you know
look look around you you know
and uh if it's not a hell yes it's a no
what you start to see is like well what
look at everything i'm okay with all
right fine which is fine then you can
have an okay life
there's nothing wrong with anything
right but if you are committed to
something
it's very
whatever you know flourishing vital
alive then you will only have in your
physical space which is that
so that would that would look like oh
you know this isn't or that might look
at that replace that cord that is that
you keep having to jiggle
or clean up the entire garage
or get rid of that thing
right like you know it's like have like
look at your stuff look at your space
maybe you have to move maybe you're
living in the wrong place yeah this is
like but then why you have a choice in
life
and you go okay got it this isn't it but
i don't have the
this or the
okay good then make a commitment i'm
going to now start looking for that i'm
going to start area i got that there's
different circumstances but we are very
proud we're intentional beings if we
really really intend something we'll go
make it happen
so you want to say well i don't have
the
resources to do this tomorrow so i give
up on it you know no
this is you this is the rest of your
life have everything be
hell yes
and you can do that there's three
ingredients to that if it's not a hell
yes it's a no
to get rid of it or
modify it so until it becomes that
like you could you know modify your
space right until it is that or
you can alter your relationship to it
to go what is this about you know you
could not change the thing but you know
really shift and go this this is what it
provides the gratitude for it
or any combination of those
and honor is critical because you go you
really know you should change it but you
don't want to do the effort but so then
you're going to pretend that you're
altering your relationship too but
you're really not
does all that make sense yep
so
uh
you know and so you have to let that
take you where it takes you
many years ago i had this big house in
vancouver
but it was very intentional but it
didn't i didn't i have no desire for a
big house but i was using it for this
community events i was using it and then
suddenly that work was done and i keep
going i'm only going to have what is
aligned so i started to get rid of and
then i ended up not only with not a big
house but i end up with only two bags
and a motorcycle and nothing else for
the last five years
because i don't hold on to stuff and i
don't come from my mind i go with what
is aligned with who i am at the highest
level right now and it changed from this
to this and went with my and life is
magical yeah it was magical when i was
there
because it served something
and it's magical without any of it
because it serves something
so you have to look at your that that
and your so there's your physical space
your space around you your stuff your
car whatever right
and as i've shared before i even go like
i only have two bags and so i have only
so much room and i every i have a
handful of t-shirts which i chose every
love every one of them
everyone in a pillow makes me smile
you get what i'm saying yeah so you you
could do that with everything you have
why do that because you can you could
have uh just stuff or you could have the
everything you own be
very useful and make you smile so choose
right
so you know that you know the
administration of your life you're like
oh i should do that i should do those
taxes or i should like you know i'm
avoiding this my email like you know but
oh by the way on that physical
clean out your computer
thousands of
i
in the spring i deleted like 5500 photos
people don't even think of that but your
computer is your physical space yep
and
hundreds of files and hundreds of emails
and wow it's so lazy
who thought that that would make as much
difference as cleaning up my room or
whatever i was like whoa i felt so good
afterwards
do you know what i'm saying
and people like yeah but whatever i said
okay well if your room if your house was
as cluttered as your computer
what they go i wouldn't walk into it
if i that much useless stuff in my house
it would be horrible okay well that's
your that's your life
it's a physical space and include you
know look in places you might not think
like your computer right
especially given how much of our lives
are computer based now
so it's physical and digital space well
digital is physical
or call it whatever you want
but that's your space
i i hold it like your physical space
it's like there yes
you know files and photos are physical
phenomena
and just see how it makes you feel i
like that um
oh just do it
do it just do it do it do it regardless
of how you feel i'm just telling you how
it felt but you know when you're on the
soccer field chasing the ball you don't
go do i feel good you're just playing
yeah afterwards you end up going hey
that was great but mostly what part of
why i was great is you didn't care how
you felt you were playing you're doing
full-out
and then relationships relationships you
want to go through you know
uh
hey again same thing it's a hell yes if
it's not
remove the relationship or
alter it
or alter your relationship to it
right
you'll see oh wow these people are not
aligned with me i i don't hang out you
know or
you know like
last year in the in the pandemic hit and
i went and uh spent uh four months with
my mother and sister
you know i work to alter my relationship
we have a good relationship but there's
still those ways they know you i'm going
ha ha we all agree that it's okay to be
somewhat that's your family but i really
took it on and i took on moving any
ounce of annoyance and now nothing my
mother or sister say even though
sometimes it could be what we call
stupid stuff or whatever
i don't have any irritation so now i
love having a joyful
and gracious experience of them no
matter what they say or do or do they
fight or whatever
so
i'm not getting rid of my mother and
sister so i alter my relationship too by
the way that's not a rule people go oh
that's family yeah nobody people walk
away from their families they go this is
toxic for me or whatever it's just that
you don't get to have a complaint
cleaning it up
you get what i'm saying
means that
you don't you
don't stay and complain about it you
either leave or clean it up right you
you may have resentments or upsets from
the past you take responsibility you
make sure they know what you're grateful
for whatever it is there's lots of
different asp things there's all those
different
methodologies about impacting
relationships
apply them find the one that's right but
yeah go through every relationship till
you're like hell yeah it's about my
state of my relationship anything that
has you is in the way of it being a hell
yes
note it and work on it
and get it cleaned up what we've done is
we've learned how to live with
what's not that
yeah
but yet in areas something that's really
that we really love or it's really
important to us we don't allow for that
it's always a [ __ ] yes when it's really
important to us but it's really
important it's like that some people you
know they love their cars they make
shorts like this some people like the
room some people like to meet whatever
it is when you really like something you
don't put up with any crap in it yeah
and then you go i love that well because
you don't put up with any crap in it
yeah
right so you do that with relationships
you know do that like i said but with
your
notice if there's any aspect of the
administration of your life that you're
avoiding doing that because it's
bothering you
and you get used to it
everybody who's listening knows that
sometimes they were avoiding it they got
it done and they go yeah
exactly
yes
right then you know and your your health
and fitness right
uh get clear about what's right for you
start doing it
and then there's a story about how dif
it's not difficult
also
it helps to find out what's right for
you because a lot of people are
suffering from my perspective again all
of a sudden
by
not really knowing what's right for them
but but thinking from what's being said
out here what should be right for them
they keep trying to match up to
something that's out here
and actually very different things
you're right for different people
so you want to slow down get grounded
and it's okay it doesn't have to be
overnight just improve something a
little bit every day
make progress
right you go okay good i think i'll just
uh eat a little bit every day i think
i'll just
add a little bit of movement i'm not
even going to exercise i'm just going to
do this just add something get
reliable at that and some people you can
dive right in you can go i'm going to do
this and i'm going to get some buddies
and we're going to start working out
regularly or whatever it is
but you can gracefully and joyfully do
it at the gradient and pace that it's
actually not a problem for you mostly
people hear this and go i gotta fix it
all tomorrow and then they fail and say
no
take a year take two years gradually
build it up for the rest of your life to
be perfect yeah
yeah i love that so it's also
um seeing the cleanup as a
uh foundation
for this one or two years of work as a
foundation for the rest of your life to
come from a pure place yes
love that okay and then so admin you
said just classical administrative
things of your life things like taxes or
things like whatever you need to do for
your business or for
passports yeah all of that stuff
yeah
cool um
yeah i like how you mentioned this
gradient and health and fitness that's
really good um to not be overwhelmed but
to take things yeah incrementally
some people might want to go all out
right away some people want to just take
it really slow um
this one the last one um state of being
or ontology we've
it's sort of uh is like awareness uh in
the sense well i mean but well yeah i
mean it starts with awareness but then
again like inside you have to act on it
right so
it's like okay so cleaning up your own
state of being is oh what am i resenting
what am i upset about what do i regret
what am i irritated about what am i
blaming like all these different things
the thoughts that keep coming in your
head and stuff so it's
cleaning all that out
such that you're no longer upset about
anything so you're no longer irritated
by anything so you're no longer blaming
it so you're no longer whatever like all
these different things
is you start to you know you're no
longer making yourself wrong about stuff
you're you know you under you start to
develop a state of acceptance and so
you're creating a clean space over here
and again it takes some time and you
know like i tell people you take you do
four years of university to prepare you
for the rest of your life
relax take a couple of years this will
make prepare you better for life than
probably anything else you can do from
my perspective
right
yeah and this also goes to what we talk
about quite a bit at nls from the law of
one material which is know yourself
accept yourself become the creator yeah
so
a real deep um
passion for you you spend four years in
university like you said well what would
it look like if
you really knew
the patterns of of your life like you
had so much awareness that you became
aware of where you were coming from and
why you were acting the way you were
acting and in just accepting yourself
fully um as you are um and as a reality
is um
and
i i think what state of being and
um
it just if it really feels like that's
where you can tell that the cleanup has
landed is that your state of being
shifts it does into more peace yeah and
all of these things impact each other
you know you clean up your
administration your state of being
cleans up you clean up your state of
being suddenly you find no resistance to
doing your exercise like you know what
i'm saying it all
it all impacts and it actually starts to
get a momentum it actually gets
easier as you go
just like after you you know when you're
learning this ski you fall down a lot
but the more you get it the easier it is
to stay up and then you can instead of
trying to stay up
or get back up like getting like so here
we are in life
when we we go these amazing experiences
like peak experiences we try to get back
up to them when we can for me that's
like trying to get up on your skis
versus if you do this work you start to
feel how to stay up and then
occasionally you fall down
and you but the more you stay up the
more that you stop looking at trying to
stay up you start to look
at the landscape which is the world and
you go wow i can go here and here and
you get better at now you can go more
and more places and you just keep
crazier hills
because you've developed the capacity
over here
it's exactly like that
and take a couple of years because then
you'll be able to ski anything or
navigate any situation in life
the way that this um resonates for me in
in my experiences that especially with
this like skiing analogy is that you
know i find myself here oh sorry let me
just add something because sometimes
people get annoyed with me with a sport
analogy fine playing the guitar
practice practice practice practice and
then go play anything then you know you
can hop into a band and just so you know
just some people and i understand
capacity that that someone that analogy
maybe it's in line for people but you
can like there's
yeah it's the same thing with playing an
instrument being a painter whatever you
know like that whatever find it in your
spin you use the thing but you practice
that thing
and then you can play
so practice practice ski anything
practice being you know your instrument
play any kind of music hop into any
situation i can play do you know what
i'm saying yes just to round out yes and
and i do understand that sometimes i
mean you focus on it but i i want you to
know
it's not a sport thing it's a
grounding integrity and capacity to play
thing
yeah okay yep yeah
yeah and you the other analogies you
gave and other ones like cooking you
gain but more and more uh sensitivity to
different ways to cook at higher and
higher levels it's sort of like training
for like an olympics or uh like for the
symphony in the city that you're in or
whatever you're going for the highest
for the highest levels and that's why i
was you know i was tying this to i've
been here since august with the team in
amsterdam
and it's really clear that the reason
why i came here was to do the work so
that i could have a cleaner foundation
for actually being a shepherd for
actually
purely serving which is honor for me
pure services is honor
and
without a doubt it's becoming more clear
that i'm skiing
in
uh greater
difficulties
yeah
and and i and i and i feel like that's a
great that's a great way of viewing it
is that um you're s you're basically
well at least i am in this case from my
perspective
seeking
um the ability to
more
uh to detect the more
subtle ways that humans express
themselves
and
help people that want to
feel more peace more happiness more
freedom
that they actually want to serve the
collective and then when they seek that
for me to actually be able to um in a
way that's empty of self-interest serve
them and so being here is exactly what
has enabled that for me
um and it's enabling most of no limit
society to train in that way
through the cleanup to become better
shepherds
if you um you know talk about
symphony or the
the olympic shocker team right you um
see
you start to play
instrumental sport you know sometimes
when you're young you can have a person
that's really a stan stands out right
they've got these really good scales and
they just dance around everybody go wow
so
the cleanup we're talking about is what
we call the ontological conditioning the
conditioning of self
right it's a foundational integrity
if you're there and you're playing in
public school and you're like running
around because you're the rock star
you're high school well you're kind of
standing out but not quite as much
and then university
see and the thing is
if you don't if you go
sometimes people are so good they get
away without doing their conditioning
you know their cardio and stuff
now your skills hide that but the
further up you go yeah the more it gets
revealed and you can have all the best
skills in the world but then the your
conditioning
allows doesn't allow you to keep up with
the game so it does not matter
yeah but
if you bring your conditioning up and up
even higher suddenly these skills come
out like boom
you know you can have like really good
you know uh
natural skill the instrument but then at
some point if you're not practicing
right
it's going to show up
so
we can
learn all this stuff
by the way every single thing that i
talk about i might say you them that's
like that every single thing that i
talked about is what i saw in myself
each step is where i saw i was full of
[ __ ] yeah so i was you could say i was
as i got interested in this work
learned a lot really and i could talk
about it really well
yeah
like a little kid being able to run
around people right likewise but i had
not done the work to embody it
and so
i could talk circles around anybody
[Laughter]
anyways so but then i and but then i
really got am i here to
play or not to make that difference and
then to so then i had to i took on a
philosophy of not teaching preaching or
informing only being and sharing so i
would have i would work to i would
not i will not discuss something to the
best of my ability i'm perfect but i
catch myself but that i'm not either
fully being
or i've declared i am not being it yet
and i'm at work on it
and here's what i'm discovering about
that right
so
if people
uh
do this work and they've done lots of
courses in reading like that stuff will
come out at a whole nother power if they
do the conditioning
of alignment and honor integrity
interesting so usually when we use the
word conditioning we talk about the ways
we've been conditioned by separation
by location by a sense of self desires
cravings aversions etc
but in this case you use conditioning in
a positive way you condition yourself
through uh repetitive honor repetitive
behavior that's empty of self-interest
yeah it's like being in good condition
like physically
you know i'm in good condition
conditioning for the game right you're
preparing like that i mean from that
perspective yeah conditioning for the
game yeah so it's like that there is
i've been conditioned over here but then
you know so
you have to do your physical
conditioning to be able to even get on
the field and play with that team this
is that type of i'm creative causative
conditioning i'm developing myself i'm
strengthening myself
yes like that yeah cool
i also really appreciated earlier when
you talked about when you don't feel a
background piece
which you could say is
this
sourcefulness this no
thingness that then if you're not
feeling that background piece everything
you do is a compensation
that's my view of it yes
and you know just also to be clear at
our human state somebody might be
listening go no no there's things that i
do that are okay fine maybe there's a
few but don't use that as a way to
escape the conversation you know some
people throw an argument in there so i'm
saying things as blanket statements as
principles as generalizations i realize
that
so
why i say this is because in the world
of being effective i would say this and
then
people would say here's the two things i
did that aren't that okay good you're
passionate about skiing or painting okay
okay fine but then
uh so then they stopped listening to the
rest of it okay what about the other 98
do you know what i'm saying not fully
okay good so i just realized as you
reflected back to me what i said i said
yeah if you're not at peace everything
you do is a compensation
it's a reaction you know versus a pure
creation yes
so somebody might stop listening to the
validity of this conversation right now
because they say no that's not true
i have two things that i do that aren't
that
that aren't that aren't a compensation
that aren't a reaction oh they actually
may actually have something
and i'm like okay fine yes you have a
few things
but it but the thing is in all of these
things is to fall into what is the
principle behind the speaking yes
so i if i was more rigorous i would say
almost everything you do maybe
everything maybe not maybe there's a few
things but where you get the power
so but our identity sometimes wants to
avoid dealing with it so it'll look for
the one flaw in the conversation
so we don't have to take it on yeah so i
just want to throw that in there you
know and i could also get more rigorous
in how i speak it's just okay consider
that a lot just a lot of what you do is
just a is a reaction and there may be
there are things you do that are purely
joyful and all of that but if you want
to elevate you don't look where it's
working you look at where it's not so
you can elevate it
yeah and this is why um you guys have
used the phrase that i'm full of [ __ ]
and that um
you know corey petuna has also talked
about it like going on the offense and
wanting to just assume like i am full of
[ __ ] so now let's look go on the offense
and i like how when you um and ben have
talked about this as well it's like
really going from a perspective of
communication actually i have a
um i have a good
of a good quote um of yours on that
on the subject
which is that
communication is the biggest place where
honor is put to the test
yeah
i don't know if it's the biggest but
it's
at least a critical
spot yeah and this is really cool
because it's where you're watching every
word or intention
everything will be revealed like
yes like i mean there's no question that
if you look at your communication
no let me say it
i could say that it's the biggest place
but then i i would come from my context
which that everything is a communication
because i also believe your action is a
communication it's communicating who you
are what's important to you stuff like
that you know so it's not just words as
a lot of people say you know
communication is only 20 verbal
but yeah everything will show up in how
you are commune what you're
communicating to the world because where
you're coming from will get revealed in
it
basically when you're talking
um it'll reveal itself because either
you'll be
coming from a place that's empty of
self-interest or you'll be coming from a
place of self-interest
and
would you say that that's typically the
most common distinction i would yes you
know are you coming service or serving
shelf
and it's also valuable to point out that
that it's not as communication is not
just words
it is in the intention of your
communication and that does come through
yeah for example
i could have a sales script in front of
me that's really well done
and i could read those words to you with
the intention of trying to get your
money so i can have a commission
right and that you will you will receive
something whatever you however
it lands right
i could also read those words to you
with the intention of uh trying to help
you and make sure that you are taken
care of
and that will land differently
you get that yep but i'll be reading
exactly the same words
so people it's
people should get that
because they go people go around just
saying all the right words yes yes it's
not that's the only part of the
communication your intention is getting
across
yeah it's it's like uh talking about
um
oneness
uh from a place of self-interest yeah
yes yeah
we're from a place of non-embodiment yes
from non-embodiment which which
the symptomatic of that is self-interest
or the source yeah it's all yes i mean
you could it's all rigorously it's
embodiment and one of the ways it shows
up definitely self-interest so they're
connected right
so when we talk when i talked
when i talked
all about this stuff with no with either
no or a
lack of embodiment you know
so you know
it was all feeding something
in myself
yeah would you this to get validation to
feel better about myself about what i
wasn't doing me too
you know and it was just uh still is
sometimes coming up yeah yeah so you
know i just saw that and the more i
cleaned up this is what this is what i
love about the cleanup
it takes more time
but the shift if you really do the
cleanup
is
it's instead of
knowing what you should do and not doing
it try to make yourself do it creating
structures to do it better
accountability partners the beautiful
thing about the
core aspect of the cleanup
was i started to want to do the things
that i thought i should do
yeah that's [ __ ] juicy yes yes yes
you see so i was not in body it should
be embodied i would have lived like that
but when the more i did the cleanup the
more than i go it couldn't be with the
lack of embodiment or it just felt right
to do it and it was like oh that's the
sweet spot
but the work is the work the work is the
work
so you when you get into good so you're
like
i don't feel like chasing that ball or
running or going up those stairs and you
get in good shape you feel like chasing
that ball you
take the stairs two at a time and it
gives you life
that's the difference that it makes
it's not linear
that's the juice
so like in a video game analogy it would
be something like where you
are
clear that going on the quest to do the
cleanup is going to take hours and it'll
be difficult but that you're going to
gain experience points and skills and
gain a next level by doing it life force
you know
everything yeah yeah your whole thing of
all the stuff you have just multiplies
with which to take on the challenges
that come next
you gain excitement to do the cleanup
itself yeah you get momentum it starts
to move it starts to seem like the
obvious thing to do
yeah you got to start you got to get
into it
otherwise this
subconscious patterns of how you speak
and where you come from will govern your
life
yes
that's my experience
so take the years now as especially like
a foundation i love this foundational
view you're you have your whole life
ahead of you yep it says like something
around this that i want a note to deepen
so i'm just going to make that no of
course
it's one of my favorite parts about
doing the the podcast is that whenever
we feature people
that there's a
a deepening of what the guest is
bringing forth
and so it's not only for you for the
audience and for your understanding of
the subject matter that's being
presented but it's also that the guests
themselves gains deeper insight into
what they are sharing based on the
dialogue that we're having
i love that component to it
and if you're looking for a place also
to do the cleanup in even more
with an even greater amount of
excitement around igniting global
awakening that no limit society is a
great place to do that it's the place to
do it and
um and you can find that that link in
the bio below
um
so we have basically what honorable has
been sharing we have that happening
for
um hundreds of people right now
and it's so so so exciting and it
becomes so much more um could you share
with us the uh insight that or the
deepening that you're excited about
well i just re the thing it's what i
already said
um that you start to
want to do
the things that you know you should do
but what i realized is that we didn't
put that in
with the nl with the no limits
and i think it's an i think it's a
valuable point
you know so sometimes i've been coming
from something
for some time
uh but it's
uh
because what i'm doing every single day
is is
is doing this work and so i start to
body it and then sometimes i don't know
what i haven't said
yes right so as i just said it to you
as i as i find it's one of the most
powerful things of this work
is that shift of letting go it stops
being strategic to try to get those
things done to what you desire
that's some cool [ __ ] which people don't
i didn't even think was possible
i thought i was going to struggle with
these things and i realized ah i didn't
get that
that's just natural for me but i didn't
get that in and i think it's powerful to
get in
with the community that's what i was
making a note of love that and so
what came up for me as you were sharing
there was that um most recently uh right
after i did one of my uh core
relationship cleanups
which you could say is like a game
within the game so doing so then you get
excited about playing that game
um you're not i i'm not excited for the
end of the phone call where i'm doing
the cleanup of the relationship
i'm not excited for the end of the call
i'm excited for the call itself which is
the game
and so then immediately what opened up
was the next deeper harder person that i
had to have a phone call with yes and i
got excited to play that game just like
you get excited to ski a harder hill
or you get excited to learn a more
difficult piece of music
yes see
then you can shift your relationship to
life where there's not things that
you're avoiding
they're just
joyful demonstrations of your that
you're playing at higher level like oh i
suddenly i can lift this weight
effortlessly so i put on a heavier
weight something that's that i struggle
with but i feel great about it because
it's a sign of my progress and my
strengthening
that is exactly it
yeah
well
if i and one of the things
also
that i feel isn't has value
is if you know
uh
one of the pieces of work that i get a
lot from is lao tzu from the way yes and
i really got
one day
oh yeah he called it the way or the path
he didn't call it the destination or the
oh
so i tell people just another way of
saying what you're saying is i said
listen
be on the path or do this work because
you enjoy it
or enjoy doing it if you have fun i
think it has value
and
uh
so
you know i
many years understood intellectually
this thing about there's nowhere to get
but i still thought there's somewhere to
get and then i actually landed in holy
[ __ ] there's nowhere to get yeah
and i didn't stop growing i got it like
oh
so if i
uh
like to ski or cook or play an
instrument
i really enjoy it i really enjoy i would
go i learned to snowboard when i was a
beginner i really enjoyed it when i was
an intermediate i mean
you don't go oh i'm not an expert yet so
i'm not going to enjoy it yet yeah
you have some people have had the best
times of their lives on a ski vacation
when they were a beginner skier did they
want to get better yes
you get what i'm saying so i really
invite everybody to get oh if you're
here
be here and have a ridiculous have as
good time as you're
humanly capable of right now
not have it get better just have right
now your full joys available right now
yes
because in fact most of you can look
have you ever had magical times in your
past
yes
had you done this development yet no
so it's not contingent on that yeah
so don't save it
if you're on the path going this is a
path i love i love this
and i'm gonna yes i'm gonna get
better
but because i love the game of that
not because there's somewhere to get yes
and i think that i think that that's a
i've found that to be very valuable for
myself yeah
yeah and i love the simple
um example of have you felt uh
ecstatic or have you felt just the
miracle of life itself uh before you did
the work and the answer is yes and so
that is yeah yeah
or even any time before right now yes
which means that you don't need any more
for that because you already
demonstrated it's possible for you
okay this was also
really cool so i've also had the
the fortune of being able to watch the
honor retreat that uh honorable did and
that will also be uh made available soon
for um for people to be able to access
and view and that
during that and i think also during an
ls you guys said that
one of the most powerful
states is when you're constituted as
something yes so when you're constituted
as fill in the blank in this case honor
that is
what you
that's what you keep in a sense at the
top in your north star position at the
top actually when you're constituted you
no longer think about it you don't think
the alternative is not an option
lao 2 said this thing he said you know
the
person of integrity has no attention
upon their integrity therefore they have
integrity
it has no intention oh no attention oh
attention attention
integrity therefore they have integrity
yeah the person who has
uh attention on their integrity uh you
know therefore lacks integrity
i would say against his standard i lack
integrity most people think
um i have a lot of integrity
um
and
um
so but it's not a judgment you know it's
like okay i'm
i attend it to it
but when i am it i will no longer attend
to it the option is any any alternative
is not an option
yes
and i'm like um it's becoming a habitual
way of living and it's actually i don't
think about it a lot but i still do
sometimes
which means i'm not fully surrendered to
it you get what i'm saying yes
so the constitution
you know i asked i asked somebody who
you know you have children yes they say
well they start they go no so what if
you have no money will they starve no
but it is no oh because it's not an
option
could it physically happen in reality
it's good but you're constituted as that
it's you'll do anything it's just not an
option you know and so and they're you
don't think about it will you give us
more examples of ways that people
uh subconsciously uh are
uh constituted in ways that they don't
even know like not letting your child
starve is a great one what's do you have
other ones i mean i don't think more are
needed uh
it's you know it's
the thing about it is and it's it's well
you know here's what's funny so people
it's like yes let me say this that's
good questions like i because some
people can go yeah but that's
because you have kids and stuff like
that so i think it's important to note
it is a choice people because it's not a
choice it's my children no some people
you know leave their children on
doorsteps or let leave them in dumb like
i can show you
all these things where people have
abandoned children not fed them all
sorts of things yeah
so um nice so it's a choice it is
constituted that way yeah like the thing
is people go oh but i didn't that's see
i think that's your fullest powers when
you're constituted but people go yeah
but i didn't do that
i'm just had a baby you know yeah no you
did yes because there's people who
didn't
yes right
so people get all serious about it and
you know people go
um
uh uh yeah no let me let me fill flush
this out a little bit so you know i
would be coaching people
and they were business businesses like
and they would go they were so busy and
jammed and you know they weren't
balancing your life i can't i can't i
just don't have the time i just don't
have the time i just i
you know i'm so jammed and i go okay
well
if your brother uh died tomorrow as a
funeral was in a different country would
you go he goes yes
why because suddenly you can do it you
don't even have to think about it i will
be there you do what's important yeah
your brother was getting married and
you're the best man will you go yes
you didn't even think how a minute ago
you told me you couldn't figure out how
to do
anything you couldn't figure out how to
work out or this or go to visit you know
but suddenly you'll be at your brother's
wedding
that's important no it's not because
there's people who don't
there's people who don't go to the
funeral there's people who don't go to
the wedding you're choosing that yes and
you don't you you don't so if i'm there
okay yeah
what what if you don't have the money to
get there fine i'll go you don't go it's
only a question of how not if
it's only a question of how not if only
how not if that's when you're
constitutionalized you never the if is
not a question i will get to that
wedding i'll do this i'll borrow money
to get there it's only i will keep fig i
will keep handling the how until i'm
there
and people that's important i go okay
well
when i was
at my first business and i was working
seven days a week and i was doing two or
three all-nighters a week and i
literally couldn't have time to see my
girlfriend my parents nothing
and i was like i can't i can't i can't i
can't and then when my favorite band the
who was doing their final concert in
toronto suddenly i was gone for four
days right
and you go that's not a wedding and
that's not this because i made that
important i made that important there's
lots of people listening who they were i
don't have time i don't have money i
don't have this i don't have suddenly
you fall in love and you're going away
for the weekend
you know suddenly you're like there's no
way i'm not showing up for that girl or
guy or whatever suddenly boom
because you made it important and the al
the option of not going
didn't exist yes
cool so we have that capacity within us
it's easy to say oh it's feeding my
children well no you do to get laid
so that's when you could say you're
fully polarized
to service to others or towards honor
you're constituted are that well the
alternative is not an option yes yes it
doesn't even occur as an option
attention on integrity is no longer
there
yeah because you would not you would not
consider anything else yes
what petine and i both found was at the
beginning
uh it took work to live with honor
because you had to think about it you
it's what i do i should do this or this
this or this
and the more you keep choosing with
honor and then suddenly it flipped to
way easier and what what flipped was
when you realized there was no question
what you were going to do it suddenly
your mind gets quiet suddenly everything
flows at the beginning it's hard it's
this and that and it takes more effort
or time or money or i don't work with
this client or like you know have to do
this properly or
and then but a lot of that is in the
struggle itself and then when you give
up the option
yeah i don't have
you already know when i show up there i
already know that i'm going to act with
honor so i don't sit around think about
it
yeah
that's what that's my experience
and i i find what you share in your
experience to be really relevant um
resonant to what i'm experiencing um
which is kind of like what you're saying
where you're you're showing up and
you're still have at in awareness the
idea of honor or it has a north star and
that over time you're becoming more and
more clear at more and more subtle
levels um
when you come from honor versus when you
don't and then over time you it becomes
more more and more painful to not come
from yes yeah and then that hurts your
heart your spirit uh enough to where
you're like enough of that enough of
that i'm done with that i'm done with
that it pops up as like a thought
advertisement to engage in a more
self-interesting way and you're like no
uh and then over time those thought
advertisements become let they pop up
less and less because you're not
selecting them you're selecting the
frames you with your choice the ones
that are around honor the ones that are
around service
um
and it really also helps to see the the
other as another self um with the all is
you because when you
when you begin seeing it as the one
infinite intelligence
talking to itself or dancing with itself
playing with itself um
with no separation at all
um
you it changes the way that that insight
if applied
changes you forever um and it it's just
it's so important applied uh awakening
is so important um
and it's done through this cleanup
um
and
yeah it's just it's so resonant and then
it's it stops showing up it's just
you're constituted as it and yeah yeah
it could be
i have a theory that if we're ever
either we don't i don't know how do i
say it it could be that the only program
that we ever needed is useful is to do
how to do what you know you should be
doing program
doing what you should be doing doing
what you know you should be doing no you
should be doing it maybe we don't need
anything else
and then if we all started doing that
then the next generation would grow up
inside of that and you wouldn't even
need that program because that's just
how we live life okay so there's this is
a really um
common uh choice point for for people
and i still experience this as well is
that you you should you should do do
what you should you know you should be
doing meaning that there's the choice
point and it's either you eat unhealthy
or you eat healthy or you um do
something that's distracting uh you from
doing the cleanup that you actually are
supposed to be doing or you do the
[ __ ] listen
everything that you
know you should be doing that aren't
doing is where your suffering comes from
yeah that's it and if you're doing
everything energy you're going to feel
great
then and this will happen this is my
experience there's a there's one layer
in there which is some of the things
that you think that you should be doing
really aren't true to you but you
inherited them from outside
so there's there's also some little
cleanup in
what is where did this should come from
but then i then you can analyze that but
i discovered another interesting thing
when you start to do the cleanup you
start to get more clear about your
shoulds and the false one starts to show
up more clearly
so if you just go to the cleanup even
that gets cleaned up
does that make sense
yeah i feel so okay okay yeah um so
your what you should be doings get
cleaned up yes like like like
there's things that you know you should
be doing like oh i should exercise more
but then you start to see
oh i should exercise this much and it's
come from outside and it's some ideals
out here
and actually that's not you know yes and
you but as you just start doing all of
the cleanup you go oh
no oh no that or that's this or my
parents think i should do this or those
who should do this and some of that's
coming from here
from own from fault standards you made
up from
the what's in our environment to wanting
to please others and stuff like that
and then
because people rightly can say to me
goes yeah but you know some of you know
those are not healthy shoulds you're
right absolutely but then that if you
already know that one then you shouldn't
do that then you know you shouldn't go
that way right so if you really just
keep doing the work and get more present
it'll sort itself out
but people want to figure everything out
before doing the work versus doing the
work is what figures it out yes
[Music]
so i saw in myself that my
constant analysis to figure it out
when there was yes it wasn't i wasn't
clear about all of it but there were
things in front of me that i was clear
of that i could start with
and i realized that my that most of my
figuring was to avoid starting with the
things that were already clear because
they were already that way because i was
avoiding them to begin with
so start with what's clear
and i promise you the other stuff will
continue to get clear yeah
and this is something that i mentioned
on our last
kata guides call so these are sort of
the people in nls that are
helping lead the groups of like 15 or 20
members that are going through the
process of cleaning up
and becoming free agents in ignition of
global awakening
and it's that the process like honorable
just said it
ends up
creating more and more
feedback onto itself by getting started
next levels show up and so in the caters
it's becoming clear that as people are
doing the cleanup they're like oh yeah i
just cleaned up this part of my
relationship and now i show up this way
and another person goes wow that's so
useful for me because now i can apply
that in my process and that
so it's like an organic cleanup it's
like a living breathing cleanup that's
happening uh with hundreds of people
and
it's
um
it's nice because it's it's also like
really hands-off in the sense that it's
just
it's it's just doing itself because
people have set the intention
to be more constituted as purity as
honor uh and then it does
it just shows up in the containers it
just it uh
like ping-pongs between uh between
people they share really relevant ways
that they've been cleaning up and how
it's
helped their state
it really helps that people share
you know the
sharing gives it life sharing normalizes
it in the environment so the environment
is raised sharing gives other people a
way to see how to impact something that
they didn't know how to do it and
sharing also goes oh i didn't even
realize
that
i had that going on but i was so used to
it that i didn't even see it as
something to clean up but now that i do
so there's i can list more but there's
numerous ways
that having sharing and having it be the
state of the community makes an
incredible difference
yes and um this also plays really well
into
you created uh three further
distinctions on these on these five uh
on the cleanup where you said that um
either it's something that you know how
to do and it's easy you know how to do
it but it's harder or you just don't
know how to do it yes and that's a good
also barometer in a sense for you to
feel okay well maybe i'm ready to do the
things that i know how to do and they're
easy and you can dive in and start with
those things
the harder ones you could maybe ask for
help yeah
with
yep
you know
but it's normal to have in those
categories
then you don't have to be disempowered
by i don't know how to i don't know how
to and
everything that you know how to do today
you didn't know at one time it was
important to so you learned or you got
support
so not knowing
is not doesn't have to be a barrier
people allow it to be but it's not it's
just like of course there's going to be
stuff i don't know how to cool
i will learn how to get support
not only will i handle it but i was
increase my competency in life
and i also recommend that people find
playful fun ways to handle all of it yes
you know people make this list and it
can be overwhelming so i say the first
thing is
notice if you're making yourself wrong
or feeling overwhelmed let it go
and that's also so make this an 18-month
project two years like whatever relax
create a joyful path to it do it at a
pace that's fun all that happens is life
gets better you have a reliable way to
100 percent make your life better every
month yes three years so what's the
problem
nice
have fun do creative sessions i remember
working with this guy once and he's like
okay what's the thing is that cleaning
his garage was one of his lists and he
just uh
so we i said no you don't get the ghost
because i'm going to go start on it no
you don't get to go start first you have
to come up
so we had to do 20 minutes of thinking
that otherwise we we always go time this
and that we're busy no to invest
effort in time
so we invested 20 minutes
in being creative versus zero typing
being creative and just running to do it
just let me run and do it right however
the creativity produced a game for him
game thing whatever uh
his three best friends have him come
over and have a clean up the garage
party
said beer pizzas cigars stuff like that
and they had a really good time
and they created the doing the stuff we
hate doing club yeah and then every two
weeks they get together and they go to
the other guy's house and they do
another thing and then they go and now
that's the thing they look forward to
the most
they're doing the stuff they hate doing
party
it's up to you it's in your hands yeah
and i really recommend people don't rush
to do i mean little stuff simple great
and it gives you energy great but look
oh here's the thing
do it when it gives you energy
so oh i just yeah i feel lit up about
doing it great i don't i'm going to
create how to
so then
what's as more
as much or more of an impact
is you build your joy muscle because you
are
rigorous about
doing it in a joyful manner
and then you stop being
one of your big whatever fears or
whatever constraints in life disappears
because you learned you've exercised a
muscle of how to bring joy to whatever
you do and you no longer have to do
things that bring you joy
and you're no longer
afraid of anything you can ski any hill
you can be in any situation in life and
you can bring joy to it that's some cool
[ __ ] yes
wow yeah to doing the stuff
we hate doing club or doing stuff that
we know we need to do club yeah
yeah and that's cool too because it does
play into the
if you want to get started sometimes
it's nice to do it with accountability
partners and so making it fun uh
bringing joy to it is so cool yeah but
make it make it
the joyful play partners instead of
accountability partners yes because if
they're if you're doing it you're doing
it so now the accountability is handled
in the background
so raise the bar you can make partners
for anything
yep
yeah that's been another um that's a
powerful
video that people when they join nls
they get as foundational content as
uh racing the bar
and um that's a great way to of putting
it is you know raising the bar for
yourself
uh to
uh be constituted as honor
and
yeah um in terms of like the most
uh the most profound things uh in my
life um this is at the top without a
doubt um
yeah
and it um it's it's exactly what
um
it's exactly what
brings
forth
um the only thing that we are
which is conscious expression and so you
may as well
make the way that you express yourself
be honor
instead of make it be
uh
for self-interest
and
then you then that way you actually
ignite the global awakening um and
there's some stuff around like models
and architect architectures that um
i'd like to also play with you on
um let me first underline something
um
to create something around raising the
bar
people can hear that different ways but
one of my experiences is that raising a
bar is very important we can call it
different things so if people hear it
differently but
it's uh what i found was is that
whether you're improving your skiing or
you're having transformation or whatever
that a lot of the
you have a burst of aliveness comes
from the new victory
yeah so raising the bar is a really
great game to play
so you have a transformation
and if you just work at sustaining it it
becomes normalized and you start to
consume it
so the every time you've had this burst
of aliveness was from the next
breakthrough from the next victory
yeah
and it has a life
and then it dissipates so
i did a whole bunch of work
and i discovered that people can live in
a very high state
if they are having a victory at least
once a week
got that thing done got that off the
list did this thing but the ex in the in
the expansion in the moving it then it's
this that's where this life force comes
forward
so go to raising the bar but not from
some significance or heaviness or i have
to but it's like wow every time i move
that bar yes i become more wait in the
gym every time you put a heavier weight
on
yeah that's raising the bar yes and then
you feel
[Music]
and you can do that for the rest of your
life therefore you can have that energy
and life force for the rest of your life
therefore you can not fear aging because
you always get you know for the rest of
my life i become more alive and joyful
yeah
so i find a lot of
value
inside of
elevation raising the bar having a
victory whatever you want to call it yes
yes
nice so
these victories in cleanup create an
increase in life force and aliveness
and then
that joyfulness gets to radiate and
there's just no fear of of death because
every single moment is just more and
more every week you take on a greater
challenge and clean up by raising the
bar
and this aliveness gets to just increase
um
yeah that's what i've experienced
sweet
and you know that's not even theoretical
nobody even has to take my word for it
just look at whatever happened every
time you
yes did that don't don't it doesn't
sound it's not some theory of mine it's
just an observation
and i just like to replicate and distill
down to what's working and i go oh that
works so let's do more of that it's like
50
little mini projects per uh year
one a week
and that each one of these mini projects
brings you way more joy more aliveness
more honor
and um what better way to do it than to
like see it as a game like see life as a
school as a game yeah okay you know you
go oh this week i did this and you know
you clean up this relationship you go
each week clean that closet cool you
know you can you don't you already know
what i'm talking about you can just
imagine this one i need that one you can
of course have five in a week but i'm
just saying you know like but every time
you you know right now that if you did
that one on the week and then you did
that one and then that one and oh my god
every week you go oh i rock you know
like
yep
yep i love how i love that that um
what's it that's like the
the taste or the texture the flavor of
that
is uh better than because it's like you
said it's the stuff you know you should
be doing flavor
[Music]
that's why it tastes so good that's why
it tastes so good
and you can throw out
the
self-love conversation
like as an activity
because you cause self-love arises every
time you take down something you know
you should do yeah
you can obsolete that conversation
you notice that every time
that you do that that you that you clean
something you do that do you notice how
good you feel about yourself do you
notice you have no negative thoughts
about yourself
yeah all those stories they don't exist
in the shadow of that when you every
time you did one of those things yeah
there's the evidence the evidence is
all i do there's nothing there's no
philosophy there's nothing there's
nothing there's nothing the work isn't a
set of this or that all i did was
observe
what worked for people just observation
it's just physics yes when you do this
this when you do this this oh okay good
if this produces this let's just focus
on this that produces that what you want
yeah
there literally is no philosophy behind
this
interesting and that's why you mentioned
the flamethrower at the beginning uh
it's yeah it's observation and it's
physics uh i love that way i love that
way of saying it because philosophy
means a love of wisdom and i think
philosophy has so much connotation um in
the last thousands of years where it's
not about application whereas right now
it's more than ever it's only
application it's just observation and
physics physics is the way it works this
action produces this right and i and
don't make me wrong i i love philosophy
you know engage in it and there's the
thing what i'm committed to distilled it
and distilled it and i said not you know
diminishing anything else i'm just
saying i'm just saying this doesn't is
not that
and i don't i don't intend for it not to
be heard that way to give new people new
things to think about
i'm just going oh look this does this
cool
that's it yeah
so if you don't you do a retreat in
workshop and take a few of these actions
and it makes life amazing
then keep taking those actions that
makes life amazing
versus have it be a peak experience yeah
i i think it's so relatable what you say
because everybody's had the experience
of doing a clean up
uh especially maybe not your state of
being that might be a tougher one for
people to get but when you do clean
something like in your physical space
everyone's done something like that
there's a period of an hour or two or
maybe even the rest of the day
where you just feel so good and there's
without a doubt no negative thoughts
emotions exactly and so
the cleanup
is a cleanup but like your house or your
kitchen you do it every day
so you do it you take you there's a
there's a bit of time over this
year
year and a half where it's a bunch
because you've let it get really messy
but it's not like you do it and you're
done
you and then you continue to live that
way
and you because stuff accumulates so you
keep cleaning it up and you actually
start to get clean up at higher and
higher levels
so it's not do this once it's about make
this the habit of your life
like if you're doing exercise a yoga
practice it's benefit comes from doing
it from the practice of it
and if you exercise you do yoga you
meditate always you always have the
benefit of this so the same way with the
cleanup the benefit is in the practice
of it
yeah and a lot of programs and stuff
they
do your inventory and you do it and
everybody so many people here as you say
have done this
and then you have this great hit from it
yeah and then i'm just like oh but then
if that does that and i really like that
why wouldn't i keep doing what gives me
that yes yes
this this also takes me to and this is
very similar with landmark and so it's
it's like when i hear about you know
your uh experience with those with that
pattern in leadership and then for
example with me it was a lot of tony
robbins and it was a lot of unleashing
the power within and being crew and this
type of stuff and it was super similar
where you would have this big workbook
and it would be answering all these
endless state when you're there and it's
just this excitement and then you want
and then that whole five-day period is
just so lit up with i'm going to change
my life i'm going to change the way i
express myself i'm going to tackle all
these things that i have to do but
the the very interesting thing is why
then are people coming back to the
retreats after six months or a year um
why and the answer is they didn't become
constituted as the cleanup itself yeah
this is great so they didn't turn it
into a habit yes
where there's no other
there's no other experience
that
you can
uh there's no other experience except
cleanup that will give you a consistent
um feeling of aliveness over your life
yeah
for
me to succeed
in my work my work should become
obsolete
yes
yes
onorak talking about honor should become
obsolete and because every single thing
i do my goal is that it becomes obsolete
yes
i hope to be useless as soon as possible
yeah
i hope my podcasting days come to an end
because everybody is just uh constituted
as the state change yeah
as being free agents for igniting global
awakening yeah so this worked
the first
shift for me was
uh you know it was in this body of work
and it was hey let's let's reach this
pinnacle let's be extraordinary stuff
like that and then
i had a shift in the view and it seemed
like a this an extraordinary mountain to
climb and let's make what we can up
however far we get and now i see it
differently i see it it's not about
reaching some pinnacle it's about the
restoration of itself to your normal
state it's not about from here going up
to there we drop we we fell away from
ourselves and just read the restoration
and then if our work becomes obsolete
and people are restored then we move
into creation and then we'll see what we
can create with this energy that we were
using just to restore ourselves that's
my view of it
and okay so when you talk about
restoration
you're talking about um when we sort of
fell
for maybe seeking uh
experiences or seeking material
possessions or substances relationships
uh external yeah okay so that was our um
falling into illusion and then the
coming back the turn within is the um is
the restoration yeah i am whole
i do not need to chase anything no thing
brings me joy but i bring joy to
everything that i do
and then suddenly
you don't need anything from the world
so then you bring something to the world
yes
so the creator principle becomes active
and that everything you paint is joy yes
so yes that's you know you move into
creation
where whatever is not holding you
makes your next action in some level of
reaction to whatever is not whole
compensate for what's not felt as whole
within you you're compensating
you're medicating yourself with every
action everything is an addiction at
some level one way of looking at it
and is that so then i'm doing it all to
i can take an opiate
or something people go that's a drug or
not but you actually people are doing
all sorts of things
to medicate their sense of disquiet nice
you know one shaman told me he said
anything
everything can be medicine and
everything can be poison
just depending on how you're engaging
with it
there's two threads there um
one of them is that
um
especially within mainstream culture we
don't typically think of
watching
like fox news and cnn
as something that is
poison
we don't typically think that we think
that you know we're righteous and we
have the right pull and we know um
and so it's basically baked in or like
the high fructose corn syrups or the
industrial oils or whatever um
they're baked in the like the business
models that are baked into the attention
economy with keeping people hooked onto
devices that type of thing um
it's
it's baked in uh to where
it's it's in a feedback loop with our
consciousness and then the the like
liberation from those oils and from the
processed foods and from um the
unhealthy patterns is uh it's that's
like the unfreezing of your will and
you're you know you're regaining it so
that you're not
so you're sovereign so you're not
you're you're not falling into and but
you you created the whole experience for
yourself i think that part is so
important that you designed the
experience for yourself to get consumed
by those patterns you chose the easy way
in the moment easy way out to get a hit
and yeah okay and so the environment
yeah every one of those industries has
scientists their sole purpose is how to
make the thing more addictive
they study that
and then they bake it into the
electronics they bake it into the
website they bake it into the food
and we can say let's blame them
but you still have a choice
i have compassion i understand i went
through all those places and
i didn't
stop doing it because they stopped doing
it i stopped doing because i chose
something else yeah
now here's a cool thing about the
cleanup
so those things
that you go i should stop eating i'm
gonna do this or i'm gonna get that app
on my phone that shuts it off for some
hours or all of those things
when
you do the cleanup you actually
naturally stop wanting to do those
things or eat those things yes
and this is not theoretical either many
people who are listening have probably
done something like a cleanse yes and
when you do the cleanse
you stop craving some of that stuff for
a while the cleanup is just a cleanse
it's a life cleanse yes
so in the same way it will impact where
you want to put your attention
so you can stop strategically trying to
work on those things
because some of those things will cease
or all of them will cease to exist if
when you get things cleaned up
when your room is really clean you don't
feel like dropping something on the
floor yes
it naturally it's natural
to create the invite clean up creates
the environment that is consistent with
who you are that you feel like keeping
it that way
yes
so the base the baseline itself is
constantly shifting
towards
a more pure expression and more
remembering of true nature and when the
baseline shifts in terms of oh well now
i felt this last week how nice it is to
have a clean physical space
now i love that example i'm not going to
bring my dirty shoes onto the carpet i'm
not going to
drop my uh my clothes on the couch i'm
going to go and put them in my closet
yes
and yeah that type of because it
continues the baseline has shifted and
so now new levels are unlocked so it's
like yes so what is the next place and
that might be digital the next place you
go no but here's and here's an
interesting thing because it's holistic
so people will often do
like a
we suffer
i have a view that we suffer from a
thing i i made up my own term for
because i call it isolationism in the
developed world we isolate one thing and
then work on one that one thing
so people could do the physical thing
and they go yeah but then after a while
it doesn't stick or whatever you know or
i don't you know i've already people
could be listening already resigned
because i've done that but i know that
it fades or whatever
but not when you do all of the areas
a cool thing happens
you clean up this thing in your
relationship
and you feel more like exercising
you feel more likely to do that
exercising and you feel more like
keeping your space clean your entire
energetic space cleans up so doing this
makes you want to keep this up keeping
that up makes you want to keep do you
get what i'm saying yep it's it's not a
linear version no matter you can be
hearing what i'm saying our
predisposition is to put it into
something familiar i promise you where
this takes you is not familiar i promise
you yeah i promise you no matter how
much this no matter how many times you
failed in the past no matter how many
times you were averted it's this is not
those things when you do all of these
things you can see how comprehensive it
is they feed each other
yes
and you get more subtle you become more
aware of
there is a place where the analogy
breaks down it's not about having a
sterile environment like it's you know
like that no it's still warm and loving
it's what's right for you and you start
to see
different kinds of impurities
like
i have a commitment to being profoundly
peaceful which has me show the dirt that
what's in the way of me being what shows
what's
yeah what's the thing you know there's
the old uh
i remember growing up there's the old
story the princess and the pea yeah you
know you know where the prince no matter
how many mattresses she could still feel
the pee so you start to feel these
impurities nice
through even more and more more
mattresses more and more and more and
more and more mattresses right and so
recently like last year i found this
disquiet
because what's in my and i what i
noticed was
like i don't have
really much any fear about anything i
don't if you're the end of my life or
anything
and i have like a little fear and i
noticed this uh i had a fear about three
things
not exercising not doing my meditation
not eating well
i know that's crit and i could go back
to times in my life where i just did
those things
i didn't have any fear about not doing
them i just did them
but now i was doing them because i was
afraid of not doing them
what the hell where did that guy used to
do them like
so i went deep in and i saw this thing
which is
the environment when i first started
doing those things there wasn't much
talk about them
right it's everywhere now right
but you know like yeah right but so like
i'm 56 i was like when i started doing
you know like it's really when i was
growing up there was none of this stuff
in the environment very little right
then
um
i
uh
there's so much talk
meditating is good for you exercise is
good for you but like i just and i and
because it was so much i let it shape
that oh
i better do those things i'm afraid not
to do those things do you get what i'm
saying yeah
and i was like wow look at that has an
impurity is coming and it was changing
the nature of those things
so i actually stopped attending to those
things
and i'm almost at this that i was part
of the cleanup because i didn't want to
have those impurities and i'm still
doing and elevating and cleaning up all
the other things and just doing it with
honor and and then i just i said i
wasn't going to take any of those
actions if i was coming from there i
literally not going to exercise if it's
coming from there if that's in the space
and after a bit
some days of not exercising one day my
body felt like exercising yeah so i did
you know what i'm saying i still
remember that really really well as a
you know at my mother's place and
and then so i just stopped and i should
i [ __ ] like that and i go nope not
coming from this to your mind no not
[ __ ] no and then and then suddenly it
felt natural and then it did for two
days and then it came back i see it's
you're back on you should do no then i'm
not then i stopped and so it was i
didn't any then it was like
start and stop starting to stop starts
and then and then it became
like that and then back into a flow
state around it but that's that's an
example of that you get more present you
see more impurities you can keep
purifying your space yeah new new ones
crept in like those ones crept in they
didn't used to be there
things like that
that's just an example from my own
experience cool that's a cool next level
um to reference as well because we can
get caught into a like a linear style
pattern which is i will do this three
times a week at a specific time and uh
and then it
there's a next level there which is
making it more flowy uh so some week you
might go three times some week you might
only go once um and
yeah and you keep doing the cleanup and
you'll find yourself and your body
falling into what nurtures it
yeah yep you'll find yourself wanting to
yes
yes
um okay let's see uh there's a couple
other
ones here
um
there's just a couple really like we can
go i would love to just get through um
these like more uh quick um with your
your hot take on them sure because these
are things that i've written from the
notes that i've taken and i love these
um
so
um
a really good question is to just ask
oneself is why are you here
and in asking that question
usually what comes up um and this ties
into this other one that i wanted to
bring up which is
what is on your bucket list
i love this one
is any service to others on your bucket
list and that's a great
that's a great realization to have um
yeah is serving the collective serving
the planet in any way serving life
where is it for you is everything on
your bucket list so why are you here
yep
cool okay
i feel like that one's um
explanatory already uh we covered um
i like this one cleanup is the best
thing you can do for your life touch
that
oh um yeah don't get caught on
sustainable improvements
also
uh
so
and yeah can you yeah
life is so as i was working on things
and learning more about the environment
came across these people and
many years ago they're talking about you
don't do sustainable they work on soil
you have to regenerate the soil
and then i learned about it and then i
got deep into the jungles and i go oh
nature is regenerative or you could even
just say generative and take out the ray
just nature is generative yes
it's not trying holding sustaining is
can i hold on
imagine
on the soccer field you get ahead by one
goal and you try to hold on to your lead
no way exactly
right so
you know um companies are you know get
this joyful startup and i want to let's
bring this to people let's cause this
and they get to this size oh let's hold
on to our things let's meet our targets
immediately the energy changes you don't
like being their customer anymore before
they wanted to bring you something now
they want to use you to sustain their
profits you know and so
sustaining
is
not enlivening it's fear-based it's
holding on and nature is not that
you know
and you know so it's a and it's actually
interesting for people to get this
because i can say this and they
understand it but then i'll show them a
picture of a cup you know some people
who regenerated a piece of land
and this is brown piece of land
and
eco or green means
not it's not sustainable it's less
destructive so that means that land gets
worse sustaining means it stays like the
world stays the way that it is
and regenerative
means it goes from brown to green
so
when you exercise
you you're generating you're
regenerating
here's the
here's the picture from oh it's got to
be because it's in focus but that's the
picture from uh 2001 of sustainable this
is what anarch showed me and then here's
the one from 2019 this is regenerative
or generative yeah yeah
you're generating life you want to have
magic in your relationships they're like
you generate it every day you regenerate
it you regenerate your fitness
it can you can hold on you know it's
it's just there's uh
so
you you everything in life is generative
like you want to bring life
you know when you're on why why even
people like playing with sports you have
to generate you're not you're just
sitting there allowing the drift of life
when it's magic is when you're
generating you're putting effort into it
yes
man i love i love how we can just
take um i love how we can just blast
through those the words sustainable but
then when we get to regenerative i like
how you even say drop the re
and just generate just generate so good
so you keep doing the clean you don't
you don't clean up lunch and then try to
hold on to that you keep elevating it
and finding more purities and you
generate you know more and more like
aliveness you just generate life
yeah
which is exactly what the
when this is a great segue into this
when um we are we're both familiar with
the kogi and so you have an indigenous
tribe in colombia
and you have the um as mama new nui said
on our show
um you have the
living original vision of earth love
living original vision of earth and
that's generative yes
which is how we're here is this
generative function yeah and um and so
yeah so it's the can yeah i love that
it's a generative cleanup it's a
generative honor
yeah
yeah so your body isn't sustaining it
doesn't have here's your cells let's
hold on they're replicating they're
reproducing they're really all your
cells are replaced in your body about
every 70 years or something like that
yes right because it's
regenerating it's generating it's always
you know it's always it's that's life
life is generative
yeah and so this is also probably why at
the beginning when you are sharing the
point the pillar one and cleanup of
physical space is um there's something
about um being
caught in the same environment that
you've been in for
years or maybe even decades in the same
maybe small city in the same apartment
in the same cluttered environment
whatever that that's why there's kind of
like this this
shock factor to
sort of taking yourself out of that
to
a
um
to to something that's not static and
that's not sustainable but that it's
generative because you can when you're
in your apartment that you've been in
for for years and it's been the same
over and over and over again that's when
you get that brown ass land in that
picture
versus when you get the green nourishing
generative land
that's when you go out of your comfort
zone that's the classic
joseph campbell hero journey um get out
of your comfort zone find some sort of
treasure which is your cleanup yeah um
and then come from honor that's right
so you know one of the foundations of
this body of work is that every person
can live their hero's journey
and um
to do that clean up to have a victory
every week yeah you have you generate
you generate what was not going to
happen it keeps you alive you just go
for it's just one structure you could
use like a victory every week but if you
do that that will keep you generating
maybe you'll be generating your
existence
not consuming the existence you already
have good so good
so the one small victory a week in one
victory a week is what
uh keeps the generator function strong
alive it does so good
horseman has a great quote and it's uh
be ashamed to die until you have scored
some victory for humanity but imagine
scoring a victory every week every week
for humanity yeah it's so good
my favorite poet e cummings said
being not dead is not the same as being
alive
yes
yeah
and um and and that also plays into what
you said a couple days ago to me which
was um you'd rather live with honor than
to die dishonorably yeah i'd rather have
an honorable death than a dishonorable
life oh yeah an honorable
death than a dishonorable life so good
and that plays into the vikings and
valhalla and
the idea of just living your entire life
for an honorable yeah for an honorable
life and an honorable death um
so good um
uh okay and this this part's also really
good is that the hill turns to a slide
this was from the honor retreat i
thought was great the what you saw as
was a hill like an uphill battle
ends up becoming when you score these
one victory a week in your cleanup it
becomes like this downhill slide
[Music]
yeah yeah and it's that thing i talked
about earlier where honor looked harder
and harder and harder until you
surrendered to it and then it was like
then you're over the hump because you
already have chosen how you're going to
operate
so instead of climbing the hill you're
skiing the hill
yes
cool and
um
here's some other um ones it was honor
is wholeness uh over the uh self part
um also honor honor is honorably living
in unity with wholeness to the best of
your ability
yeah i mean there's no there's no honor
without the wholeness because it's honor
in relationship too
you know you're not isolated as a
phenomenon
yeah oh that's so good so honor is
always in relation to
and so then you're always thinking of or
at least not you're at least when you
start you're keeping your attention on
this which is how am i in relation to
yes to other people to the world
excellent uh and then
okay let's do
um so onorak uh you've been um
uh you've been
excited and designing and implementing
new models
and i find this to be really interesting
because i found things like the
sustainable development goals something
that i got really excited about a couple
years ago and i was like heck yes this
is so cool we have these um these
visionary 17 ways of like seeing zero
hunger clean water and then people
coming in uh to want to create solutions
to those things and to meet basic needs
and and then when i was talking to you
you you made it clear that like that's
actually still coming from the like
band-aid mentality um whereas if you
come from cleaning up first
then your solutions that you create will
be more aligned with things like the
seventh generation principle in
indigeneity where you're actually not
thinking about the
solution to clean water that's for a
billion people that's going to be uh
just this decade but you're thinking
about clean water in the next
250 years you're looking at there will
never not be clean water ever again
yes
right so
we have there's this thing called the
problem solution mass that you talk
about every every
solution becomes the next problem
you know so you could have say oh uh
a solution to shortages of water now
people are ramping up desalination
yeah right and that if that starts going
like crazy instead of people changing
their habits of how they use water
then we'll desalinate
the oceans and at some point that's
going to throw something off in the
balance of the ocean it can't not we've
already learned that
so we keep doing a short-term solution
versus
how are we going to alter our habits so
we don't have this problem anymore
now i understand
that that
there's things to take care of in the
short term
so let's use those solutions sourcefully
to take care of people right now
but not live like that's
but the real
shift happens
when
we
handle things at source
source solution-based intervention in my
these are my own stuff i've made up
i used to do that but i realized that
the solution validated the existence of
the problem and allowed peop the problem
what had the problem be there to
continue to exist
versus source based is you go back and
create a world where you're no longer
that problem is no longer being
generated yes
and uh i love the
you said
um
he says it was
it was like c and you know bentino talks
about this uh a lot as well it's that
you see
um the future
where everybody has clean water as
already done and then you work your way
back
from that future vision
yeah that's one way of looking at it for
sure you know you go this
you know that what is it needed for that
pro problem to no longer exist
yep
um
and so now let's let's hear from you on
some of these new models and
how many uh
of the different because i i don't even
know of this from you yet but where
where are the new models so what are the
new models and where are they being
implemented you have some schools some
like cities some like like designs of of
homes and uh ways that yeah so what i
looked at was so i i took on so i keep
my word to impact the planet so i did
many years of research and study about
what causes large-scale change
that's when i left
you know leading programs and things and
i said okay i came to conclusion that my
path was
what i saw what causes large-scale
change is to build better ways of doing
things
so we have a philosophies criticize
nothing
offer a compelling alternative
so like they created the airplane or
they created a compact disc and
everybody switched over nobody had to
make
vinyl records wrong or whatever you have
the cell phone doesn't mean landlines
are wrong but now the cell phone's in
everybody's hands
so i go look at that there's evidence
that the entire world can change in a
very short period of time if you give a
powerful so i stopped working on
changing the world but instead to create
a new world which everybody would want
to move to a no-brainer a no-brainer so
then i went away from a lot of my work
which was creating improvements in lots
of things but still perpetuating the dna
in the world that they were from and to
leave it and to go away to create new
things
and i first picked four pillars which
moved to five which was education
wellness
business
and media
and then now it's also homes and
communities
and then it created my organization
which is called fu stands for fun
unlimited
but people people are welcome to
misunderstand it uh
limited and our our mission is to have a
ridiculously good time
creating new models
new ways of doing things
that has caused all of life to flourish
and alter the trajectory of the planet
and so
um
you know so we have the life
regenerative business model
which is
that in that model people do this work
to generate their lives in an aligned
state
i learned
how to obsolete some of my work already
if i create an environment where people
are joyful passionate alive all sorts of
these organizational problems no longer
exist they didn't need my stuff to fix
those things there's no conflict
resolution because there's no conflict
and you know
then also at the environmental and also
environmental level i realize that when
people are joyful and fulfilled they
don't need to buy and consume more stuff
you know so
you know that so it impacts that and
that's when the mama said you don't just
plant trees you have to heal your hearts
oh cause when their hearts are healed
we're not so consumptive
um and so
so in this model
we there's there's it's generative of
the human life
and we reduce the footprint of the
business as much as possible and then we
make sure resources from the earnings go
back to a net positive not to an offset
yes right so if i'm making 40
units of impact on the environment i put
60 units back into the earth
and then now if you use that model then
you can be relaxed passionate guilt-free
because everything you do is generative
of life
right
in the homes
uh and communities we're doing we've
come up with an entirely new approach to
designing anything
so let's example so if i showed you our
this is in process of design and we'll
be building some prototypes soon but
we're looking for every element we can
think of that impacts life
so we have
air quality or we have
regenerative farming we have food we
have fitness we have
water and waste systems walls and
electricity we have
joy laughter play
sleep
we're bringing things into the design
and so it went from a housing project to
a living project yes we went from the
best possible house to the best possible
living
and so that the even the environment
promotes living the things that we're
talking about and how do you build that
into the environment of the home of the
community and it's you know and we're
building healthy homes with
no toxins and this and so that's
um so
uh and it's really challenging we're
coming like it's really coming to how do
you design stuff that nobody's ever
designed before
so we're coming up with um
a whole new structure
of thinking in design
and um yeah
and and doing it with with the intention
that it's impact the planet it's not
just building better things one of my
mandates is everything we learn here so
every one of those things air quality
what's the highest possible outcomes we
could produce in air quality
what are all the different ways to
educating people in that what's the
you know this that what are all the
different ways that can be done and in
that list of how it can be done has to
be ways that people can do that in their
existing homes because most of the
population is not going to build a new
place so if we're going to serve earth
it can't just be here's how to build now
no it's got to be and here's what you
can do here's how you can elevate joy in
your current environment or or air
quality or this or that so it's it's
about service to the whole
we have a philosophy that's with the
world for the world so in the next six
months we'll be building websites for
each of these things and allowing
anybody in the world who has wants to
contribute expertise to building
to education to contribute in anybody
who wants to learn from we're doing to
take it and put it out nice and our goal
is to build an international community
in each area
uh who is committed to revolutionizing
that area and open source all of it and
have it be a living growing phenomena
um you know uh
so you know right we're gonna we're we
have a school in mexico that we're
starting at ground zero that's gonna be
we're gonna be showcasing and you know
we have without even presenting it yet
we have people showing up we have
another group in costa rica that want to
build a school then okay let's learn
from this and we'll share what we have
so it's you know it's taking root
i started work on that school uh in june
um
and um on the building stuff we've got
uh four or five people said yes i want
to build that prototype with this we
have land we have a couple of people
there's a guy in canada that's donated
150 acres of incredible like beautiful
land saying build a community give it to
i don't need any money just as long as
it makes a difference so
uh this is without having to put the
word out yet so we're excited you know
it's good it's like you know and it's
very pure we not interested in just
anybody
it's not a community to get away from
the world it's too it's to be a living
laboratory for the world always of
service
um you know the the the business model
we're working with some
people around on on the wellness uh
aspect uh you know one guy is building a
wellness community a village in the
states other things
um
we have got a team around media we work
you know every week deeply on how to
actually create media that's really fun
engaging and it makes a powerful impact
um
you know we've got all sorts of things
we've got
uh you know we're bringing nephew to
everything we're like uh we've got uh
we're creating the design for a fun role
so you can have fun funerals oh a
funeral right and uh and so like uh you
know we're looking how do you have
funerals be hilarious they celebrate the
person's existence we're coming up with
ideas like the person can put money
aside
uh and then for the next 10 years we'll
uh
play jokes on their friends and family
and make them laugh after they're gone
or whatever it is we're just coming up
with stuff but you know we're creating
so there's those pillars but then we
look at wow if people learn all of this
stuff this is what i learned many years
ago is that people learn all this stuff
but then they're sent back into an
environment where the dna is created
from something else so what serves
people is to give them the
things that are built from this so they
can live it not struggle against it you
know we're creating the worst foot
forward dating agency which is creating
an agency where people it's about not
about you know being yourself fully like
that and it's very funny it's going to
be a very silly thing but anyways but
we're looking okay what are all aspects
of life how do we fu anything in life
yes
cool so then it's become clear that the
um the state changes from the cleanup
they create better architectures that
are sourceful but also that the more
sourceful architectures uh feedback they
enable that state change to stay uh and
not only to stay but to generate but to
keep spiraling upwards the school itself
one of the assignments we'll be giving
the kids is you're going to help us
redesign the school one of the things in
the curriculum is that every year one of
the topics is redesigning the school for
next year
yeah that's great right
each thing the uh we're totally we're so
impacted by our architecture and
environment around us
you know if we're in a noisy pub we'll
be talking loud if i walk us into a
church our behavior will change
instantly yes if i try to get you to
yell in that church you won't feel like
it your environment pushes and pulls for
what exactly the way that it is so if
you come to and work my workshop
i was like what's going on how come
everybody draw oh i'm doing in some
level a disservice like
i'm creating an environment
that is so carefully designed for
people's expression connection
authenticity or whatever right
and then we throw them
100 miles an hour back into an
environment that was for who they used
to be yes so they go oh no we have to
redesign those things and
and call for them and you know my early
which is why they come back to the
retreat six months because that's the
only place they can
have that right versus to nurture that
to redesign their entire existence
that's oh well let's give them a
workplace that is that let's give them
school that is that let's give them you
know their home environment that is that
right
and um
you know so it's just like uh
like my early successes became failures
like i helped you know
what do you want i want to grow my
business i would
help the guy he tripled his business but
was he any happier no more stress and i
really looked the thing about it was
this
so
that early business work mo i saw oh
most people's
businesses they either inherited from
family or they started it and it's all
serving a variety of intentions that
aren't sourceful
right
yeah you know doing this lack belief
whatever right so there's
lots of it
and there might there might even be
elements that are but lots of elements
that are not
so there was not a pure expression of
self
so it was an architecture and
environment that is not an expression of
you
and then i just
tripled the not you that you were living
in oh wow and then it was even worse
because now you're more addicted to it
because it's making you more money
jeez
so
you had to take a lot of things at park
yeah
wow what an that's such a good way of
putting it because the conventional
mainstream mentality is take what you're
doing and find ways to just grow it no
matter what
but that's so off because if it's coming
from a place of
ignorance of of the nature of just
coming from a place of self-interest or
seeking validation or unworthiness or
whatever it is that uh it's
you're growing something that's creating
more cancer for life
um
and that itself is such a because
everything that's so much of what's
being peddled in mainstream is growth
growth growth no matter what growth
growth growth this is such a good way
actually you had a story that i thought
was really good too where you basically
um had a decree oh yeah the b
r p business reduction program yeah i'm
working on a couple of things i i for
years i had programs on people on how to
grow their businesses and make more
money now i'm developing programs on how
to reduce your business and how to spend
your money
right which is how do you spend your
resources in a way that is really
aligned and gives you the most
yeah it's aligned how do you um have oh
this business causing me stress let's
actually reduce it to the perfect size
like this
nature grows to something no your body
you don't go
oh let me keep going let me go to 100
pounds 200 pounds 300 pounds for you
don't do that you want to get to your
perfect
size yeah
you want to get to your perfect size you
don't want to keep growing
the perfect size in which you are the
healthiest most vital and alive yeah
and so i had this client was working
with and it was it was the uh the
natural let's go i wanna double my
business okay let's then we start i said
and i go but now but then i had learned
to go down to somebody's core intentions
and like why and this and that okay
because what he wanted was to travel
more with his family mountain bike a lot
more stuff like that so over time
we reduced his business from 2.2 million
to 1.2 million
and from eight staff to three and nobody
only does
he says yes to work that he loves
and he has way more time to
to do exactly he travels with his family
now he has everything lined up exactly
how he wants
so what he was
which is what he wanted from growth
rather than let's just have it now
yeah what you need to do is get rid of
some stuff get rid of some of the
company and stop saying yes to work that
didn't enliven them yes
yeah if it's not uh [ __ ] yes then it's a
no it's a no um and and uh another one
that came up when you were saying i
weigh 100 pounds 200 pounds 300 pounds
400 pounds is like okay one kid two kids
three kids four kids five kids you know
what's the perfect amount which is for
you
um and then what's like one car two cars
three cars four cars five cars no what
is the right amount of cars or whatever
like that that's such a great way of of
putting it and another good one is like
what yeah your unique
expression of the creator is
whatever you feel like it is it's not uh
it's not funneling into the same 1
million 2 million 3 million 5 million 10
million mentality um that's so good
because
um i talked about it also like a
a palette of colors also and that
there's
um all of these different ways to
potentially express yourself just as a
good parent as a good community member
um
all the way to whatever a fortune 500
ceo or whatever and so there's all these
different ways to express yourself and
um
yeah
okay cool i feel i feel really good we
covered new models i fun unlimited and
the um the five focuses uh so living um
health or fitness
education media
and business and business yeah those are
the five core ones and then all you know
and then
other you know expanding into ideas to
have every key area of life have have a
model those ones i think are most
pivotal
for all of life yes and the i the idea
is is not
the change
will be not from what we do in those
areas but that
proof of concept of that way of
approaching things and people with a lot
smarter than us and a lot more resources
taking on that way and bringing it you
know we just want to demonstrate you can
do it this way and it gives more of
everything that you want
so there's no reason it's a no-brainer
switch over to this way of operating
yeah
it can be done it's just a different
platform like uh
yeah philip said we're gonna change the
way people listen to music they spent a
bunch of years created the compact disc
it was so compelling everybody moved
over and it changed the way people
listen to music yes
and then everybody everybody put their
music on it
so it's not about just somebody's music
it's not just about our work it's
whatever it is i don't care about that
much it's that this way
could be brought forth other people have
all sorts of brilliant work and stuff
like that people's uh
brilliance and creativity is amazing you
know i just want to create what would
unleash that i already know all
everything that's needed to cause the
world to flourish is already out there
yes just to help make that a channel for
that yep
and um very similar to how it became a
no-brainer to shift towards spotify and
streaming services now and so there was
a compelling enough reason for people to
feel like it's a no-brainer and now
everybody streams um their music now and
it's very similar now going to be with
these five pillars with the way that we
transition with fun unlimited turning
the whole earth into a big uh birthday
party
you could have the way business now or
you could have a business where
everybody's life's just rocks and it's
making the earth healthier you could you
could have this for this choose
you could have people living the life
that's so joyful and flourishing
now because we work this way versus i'm
going to work for decades hopefully earn
enough money to be able to live life
that way one day maybe
yes
and i loved when you were sharing you
shared that
this is a very like decentralized
crowdsourced approach to this so meaning
these five categories with fun unlimited
that you have people from around the
world that are excited about these
next-generation architectures so they
contribute their ideas to some sort of
an ecosystem of the ideas and structures
then they can take from that ecosystem
and implement it into schools or into
media or business
into living and i love that you don't
say housing you say living i love that
and i i really like that that's totally
the future this like idea pool of great
structures and people contributing and
using
so i'm excited to create with you more
on that and also to introduce you to
some of the people that are making big
changes in the space um that we've had
on the show before people like my
brother andy bittner super excited for
you guys to create together um and to
explore
and
um
so for more of uh for more of onorak uh
you can find the link in the bio to his
facebook profile and you can if you feel
like it's relevant or resonant for you
to reach out and be able to collaborate
or contribute to these things from a
sourceful place um you can reach out and
follow him there because he doesn't have
much of an online presence you'll notice
another thing is you can find his he has
two episodes on mirror talks with
bentino episode 12 and 13 which are both
on youtube you can check out for more um
information on purifying where you're
coming from courage fearlessness staying
true
um
also um if you probably if you want more
of honorable getting involved in no
limits society is another great place to
find more of him um
and that links in the bio below as well
the ongoing program for training free
agents for ignition of global awakening
um
yeah i think that pretty much covers
most of what we want to talk about where
people can find you you feel like
complete intentions good yeah i feel so
too i i found it interesting that at the
very beginning that there was a like a
slower flow i've also experienced that
before with a guess on the show um but
uh sometimes i feel like it comes from a
place of wanting to like bring structure
of like talking about the person's
journey and how they got to where they
got to and then sometimes i just don't
do that at all and i just ask like like
hey welcome onorak so what is honor
and like that type of uh entrance into
the conversation and so
like feeling into that i just love how
it was just we got to this flow and it
felt so good um being able to rock
together like that on the subject and i
look forward to more explorations like
this together
and hopefully it brought great value for
people and
um if it did we would love for you guys
to leave a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode
comment below with how you've cleaned up
and how that's uh enhanced your
aliveness and your state change um
and
uh also yeah you can uh like the video
that helps algorithm to get it to reach
out to more people subscribe to the
channel if you haven't yet also share
the video uh with other people share
what honor is um for you with other
people so share beingness and sharing
with the two yeah what what it's like
this uh yeah
be it and share it you know that's
different than preaching it
yes you know work on it and share what
you're working on work share because
it's you're engaged in it
not because you
want validation from knowing something
yes
yep
um so we we would love for you to share
um with people like you you you've
practiced you've cleaned up and how it
positively and your life you can also
share here's what you're grappling with
or whatever you know it's it's natural
to so we don't want to suppress the
sharing
and even that you know you can share
here's this or here's where i struggle
like this is what i got when you're
sharing you don't have to have it worked
out to share with people saying here's
what i'm working on here's what i'm
struggling with here's like that there's
an authenticity is always been for me
more powerful than strategy so share to
share see what sharing does sharing
makes it more alive makes it real gives
you momentum just sharing even your
struggle can have disappear some of the
struggle
right so it's it's all all of it you can
share this thing that you're talking
with and somebody can respond to your
share and say hey try this
you can create an opening for being
supported naturally by the natural flow
like in the ecosystem where the water
wants to flow to create an opening for
it
so it's not about having it together
it's about being authentic being free be
yourself
so good um
and hopefully the the honor retreat also
will be made available soon we'll have
that link in the bio when it is made
available where anurag and bentino went
into this in more depth
um
and yeah step up this is the this is it
this is the only thing um like we talked
about like onorak shared this is the
cleanup is the foundation um for the
rest of your life and uh and one victory
every week to increase your aliveness
and
um
and build on that momentum and play the
game play the game and play the game
onarak thank you so much you're welcome
it's good to be here so cool thanks for
hosting that so cool yeah so cool i i
love your heart again i just love your
spirits so much
so cool
thanks everybody again for tuning in
infinite love for you and um
that's all that's all folks
um thank you
okay
bye
ooh got a little longer than i thought
[ __ ] i got to get something done before
the movie